Mind Your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
Triangle ABC has an inscribed circle I.
The inscribed circle is tangent to BC at point D.
If the radius of the inscribed circle is 15,
BD = 26,
and DC = 25,
what is the area of triangle ABC?
Pause if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
I'm first going to review the concepts used to solve this problem.
These will be equal tangents to a circle,
the area of a triangle from its in radius,
and Heron's formula for the area of a triangle.
We'll get started with equal tangents to a circle.
Consider circle P, and an exterior point A.
Construct tangents AB and AC.
We want to show that AB = AC.
To do that, we'll construct radii PB and PC.
We then construct AP.
It's obvious now that ABP and ACP are congruent right triangles.
To be more explicit, notice that AP is a hypotenuse length W.
Therefore, the remaining leg in the right triangle
will be equal to √(w^2-r^2), and
that's true in both of these right triangles.
Therefore, AB = AC.
Now, let's derive the area of a triangle from its inradius.
In a triangle with sides ABC,
consider the inscribed circle.
Draw radii to each of the points of tangency.
We can therefore partition the triangle into three smaller triangles.
One triangle will be alongside A. This triangle will have an area of AR/2.
This triangle alongside B will have an area of BR/2.
Finally, the triangle alongside C has an area of CR/2.
We can simplify this formula, and then factor out the r.
We thus have r(perimeter)/2.
The perimeter over two is known as the semi-perimeter, and often abbreviated as s.
Therefore, the formula is rs.
Finally, we have Heron's formula for the area of a triangle.
It'll be equal to the following expression:
√(s(s - a)(s - b)(s - c))
Here, s again is the semi-perimeter.
I'll now briefly give a proof of Heron's formula.
By Al-Kashi's law of cosines, c^2 = a^2+b^2 - 2ab cos c.
In this equation, we'll solve for the cosine of angle C.
We'll then use the identity that sin C = √(1 - cos^2).
Substitute that in, and then simplify.
We then use a formula that the area of a triangle = (1/2) (ab) sin C.
Again, we substitute and simplify.
We're now going to use a lot of algebra to simplify this equation.
First, we have a difference of squares so we can factor it as follows.
We're then going to factor each of these terms, and then
We have another difference of squares, so we factor each of these quantities.
We then simplify this formula.
Now we're going to take that 1/4 and put it inside as 1/16.
We can distribute this to each of the 4 terms, because 2^4 = 16.
Finally, the semi-perimeter = (a+b+c)/2.
So, the first term will be s, the second term will be s-c,
the third term will be s-a, and the last term will be s-b.
We substitute those in, and then we slightly rearrange this formula,
and we get exactly Heron's formula. We've proven it.
So now, let's use each of these concepts to solve the problem.
First, equal tangents.
BD=BF. Therefore, BF = 26.
Then, CD and CE are equal tangents. Therefore, CE = 25.
Here, if AF = x,AE = x.
Consequently, side AB = 26+x,  AC = 25+x,
and BC = 26+25 = 51.
We will now calculate the area of triangle ABC in two different ways.
First, we'll calculate its area from the inradius.
We first calculate the semi-perimeter.
This will be the perimeter/2. This simplifies to 51+x.
The area will be rs, which will be equal to 15(51 + x).
We'll put this equation to the side.
We then use Heron's formula.
So, we have the formula, we've calculated the semi-perimeter,
and we substitute in to get the area of the triangle in this form.
We thus have two equations for the area of the triangle, which we set equal to each other.
We now systematically solve this equation to solve for the variable x.
This is basic algebra, so I'll just go through it quickly.
We then end up with x = 27, but we're not trying to solve for x;
we're trying to solve for the area of the triangle,
So we go back to the formula for the area and then substitute, and we get the answer of 1,170.
I love [that] this problem involves so many different concepts from geometry.
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube.
As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support.